the issue I see within the election
right now is that we're not having the
conversations that matter to people and
families across the country we have
moved so far away from the
bread-and-butter issues that families
want to talk about so we haven't heard a
lot about poverty we haven't heard a lot
in this election about bringing and
making sure that we have a strong social
safety net not only for low-income
families but for middle-class families
who are still fragile or straddling
between being financially secure and
close to the edge in terms of falling
into poverty and we're just not having
those conversations we're talking about
things that matter but when we talk
about building a society where all
people have a fair shot we're not
talking about the issues that will make
the difference for them we don't talk a
lot about white poverty and I think we
should because I think if we talked a
lot more about the way poverty impacts
different groups I think we would not
see it as an issue that's out there and
doesn't impact me or it's a black issue
or a Latino issue we would see it as an
issue of lack and people not having the
resources that they need to be able to
live the quality and productive life
what we know though is that black and
Latino people are more likely to live in
poverty and white people are also poor
but we're not again we're not talking
about those conversations and we're not
even writing about those conversations
so when we're not talking about rural
communities and rural White's
those people are invisible in media and
culture when we're talk about poverty
and so until we can really wrap our
minds around the magnitude of who's
living in poverty and what poverty the
face of poverty and what it really looks
like we're not really going to be able
to make policies that will reach the
people who are really impact
are affected by it one of the things I
think is unique about American poverty
is the gap between the wealthiest and
the poorest in our society and that gap
continues to widen and there are no
efforts to close the gap to make sure
that the people at the the bottom of the
economic ladder have the resources and
they need to just have a basic standard
of living there are no efforts so for
example you can work 40 hours a week get
up every day go to work and still need
other resources and supports to be able
to make ends meet
whether that's housing whether that's
Food Stamp whether that's medical
insurance and that shouldn't be the case
here I think that we really need to pay
attention to what's happening to the
most vulnerable and the fragile middle
class who are sometimes a paycheck away
from living in poverty or being in
poverty themselves what frightens me is
that there's not enough more
responsibility for others in our society
and so we can just turn our back we can
say hey that's not me that doesn't
impact me or that's happening to them
and not to me and not seeing the
connection between us all if I support
programs that make sure that the the
most vulnerable in our society have what
they need to have a basic standard of
living that somehow takes away from me
if we can get away from that idea and
that sort of thinking then I think we'll
be able to get to a place where we can
say this is not an us then problem it's
a problem that we all need to be working
together to solve